Guckt mal: Ich tippe hier einfach ein "Ich
will eine Website machen, die nach Eingabe
des Geburtsdatums das aktuelle Alter anzeigt.
Kannst du mir den Code dafür schicken?"
Und dann schickt mir ChatGPT den Code in HTML
und Javascript.
Ok, das ist jetzt noch nicht so beeindruckend,
weil es solche Codeschnipsel natürlich auf
vielen Programmieren-Lernen-Websites gibt
und das einfach copy-pasted sein kann.
Jetzt gehts aber weiter: Könntest du machen,
dass das alles schöner aussieht?
Also eine völlig unkonkrete Frage, ab er
trotzdem kriege ich daraufhin Code ausgespuckt,
der ein tatsächlich schöneres Ergebnis liefert.
Aber jetzt wirds wirklich verrückt, jetzt
schreibe ich nämlich: Könntest du einen
Kasten um die Geburtstagsabfrage machen und
noch ein hoch und runter hüpfendes c't-3003-Logo
einbauen?
Zack, neuer Code, das sieht dann so aus.
Und jetzt wird's noch verrückter, denn es
stellt sich raus, dass die Website gar nicht
funktioniert.
Wenn ich das Ganze als HTML abspeichere und
in den Browser lade, wird nie das korrekte
Alter berechnet.
Da steht dann immer nur "NaN".
Deshalb sage ich jetzt zu ChatGPT:
Das Alter wird nicht korrekt berechnet, bitte
korrigiere deinen Code.
Ja, und das macht er dann tatsächlich; und
jetzt klappt die Berechnung auf einmal.
Ich habe dann noch drum gebeten, einen animierten
Sternenhimmel in den Hintergrund zu packen...
ChatGPT kann übrigens nicht nur programmieren,
sondern auch Witze erzählen, Aufsätze schreiben
und seltsame Dinge erfinden.
Bleibt dran!
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internetsurfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei...
''WERBUNG*
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von AVM aus Berlin.
Jo, AVM hat mir gerade die neue Fritzbox 5590
Fiber geschickt.
Ich habe die direkt testweise mal angeschlossen,
tja, und ich kriege wirklich direkt deutlich
mehr Durchsatz über WLAN -- obwohl auch mein
alter Router schon Wifi-6 hat -- aber halt
nicht mit der 4x4-Antennenkonfiguration der
Fritzbox 5590.
Das Gerät arbeitet an Glasfaser-Anschlüssen,
hat etliche Smarthome-Funktionen eingebaut,
unterstützt FritzApps auf dem Smartphone
-- und obendrein ist es auch noch eine vollwertige
Telefonanlage.
Mehr Infos zur Fritzbox 5590 Fiber auf avm.de.
*WERBUNG ENDE*
Am 30. November 2022 ist ChatGPT öffentlich
gestartet -- und fünf Tage später meldeten
die Macher bereits eine Million User -- das
zeigt recht anschaulich, wie groß der Hype
um ChatGPT ist.
Auf Twitter sprechen Leute schon davon, dass
wir es hier mit einem historischen Moment
zu tun haben; auf einem Level mit der Erfindung
der Elektrizität oder des tiefen Tellers.
Und: Google könne ja nun dichtmachen, so
gut sind die Antworten von ChatGPT.
Aber stimmt das wirklich?
Zuerst mal: Was ist überhaupt ChatGPT?
Tja, es handelt sich dabei um ein sogenanntes
"Großes Sprachmodell", also ein Large Language
Model, also ein mit riesigen Textmengen trainiertes
neuronales Netz.
Wenn ihr detaillierter wissen wollt, wie sowas
funktioniert, empfehle ich euch die c't-Uplink-Folge
über GPT-3. GPT-3 kommt von der gleichen
Firma wie ChatGPT und das ist OpenAI.
OpenAI hat übrigens auch den Bildgenerator
DALL-E entwickelt.
Und finanziert wird OpenAI unter anderem von
Elon Musk und Microsoft.
ChatGPT ist zurzeit offen für alle und kostenlos
zu benutzen, man muss allerdings einen OpenAI-Account
anlegen und da Mailadresse und Hanynummer
angeben.
Während das ältere GPT-3 für Leute, die
nicht coden können, noch etwas umständlich
zu bedienen war, ist ChatGPT jetzt so simpel
wie Google: Einfach eintippen, was man will.
Und zack, Ergbnis.
Und anders als Google, spuckt ChatGPT wirklich
eine konkrete Antwort aus und nicht nur Links
auf andere Websites, wo man die Antwort vielleicht
finden könnte.
Schaut mal hier, wenn ich Google frage, warum
der Himmel blau ist, dann kriege ich zwar
direkt eine hervorgehobene Antwort, die bezieht
sich aber nicht konkret auf meine Frage.
"Jede Farbe hat eine andere Welle" ist auch
ziemlich seltsam formuliert.
ChatGPT dagegen liefert mir eine konkrete
Antwort -- und das tolle ist: Ich kann sogar
sagen, dass ich die noch einfacher haben will.
"Der Himmel erscheint blau, weil das blaue
Licht vom Sonnenlicht stärker gestreut wird
als die anderen Farben."
Das ist doch echt eine ganz gute, einfache
Antwort.
Wenn mir das ZU einfach ist, bitte ich um
eine detailliertere Antwort; ich kann sogar
Detailfragen stellen, zum Beispiel nach den
konkreten Wellenlängen, worauf ChatGPT dann
kontextbezogen antwortet -- also ChatGPT merkt
sich, worum es in den vorherigen Fragen ging.
Und auch das kann Google nicht, da muss jede
Suchanfrage für sich stehen.
Also, kann Google jetzt echt dichtmachen mit
ihrer Old-School-Suchmaschine?
Nee, denn ChatGPT hat ein Problem; und das
sind die Fehler, die sich da immer einschleichen.
Hier zum Beispiel: Da sagt, ChatGPT, heise
online wird von der Heise Media Group betrieben.
Es gibt aber gar keine Heise Media Group,
es gibt nur die Heise Medien GmbH & Co und
die Heise Gruppe GmbH & Co.
Bei einer weiteren Anfrage haut ChatGPT einfach
so locker raus, ich sei ein Kabarettist und
Musiker, der durch seine Musik-Comedy-Shows
bekannt geworden ist.
Ich glaube, das weiß ich besser, ChatGPT.
Und das Ding ist: Es reichen ja schon 5 Prozent
Falschaussagen, um das ganze System ziemlich
unbrauchbar zu machen -- denn man weiß ja
dummerweise nicht, WAS falsch ist, wenn man
sich mit einem Themengebiet nicht auskennt.
Bei Google gibt es natürlich auch viele Falschinformationen,
aber da wird ja zumindest die Quelle angezeigt
, man kann also die Wahrheitswahrscheinlichkeit
einigermaßen einschätzen: Einem peer-reviewten
wissenschaftlichem Paper kann man vermutlich
ganz gut trauen, einem Tweet von irgendeinem
Honk auf Twitter eher nicht.
Tja, und ChatGPT zeigt leider eben nicht an,
wo die Informationen herkommen.
Die Fehler passieren nicht nur bei Sachinformationen,
sondern auch in Programmcode, am Anfang des
Videos hatte ich euch ja schon den nicht funktionierenden
Geburtstagsrechner gezeigt.
Ich hatte sowas ähnliches schon beobachtet,
als ich nach einer Website mit dem Bild eines
springenden Raspi gefragt hatte.
Beim ausgespuckten Code waren die CSS-Eigenschaften
in einer Zeile falsch, weshalb das ganze Ding
nicht funktionierte.
Tja und ich habe ChatGPT dann seinen eigenen
Code copy-pasted und gefragt, was daran falsch
ist.
Und ChatGPT hat dann tatsächlich den Fehler
gefunden und korrigierten Code ausgegeben.
Das ist ziemlich cool, aber verlassen kann
man sich darauf nicht.
Ohnehin muss man natürlich sagen, dass das
System noch in einem frühen Stadium ist und
deshalb noch unzuverlässig arbeitet; viele
Antworten brechen mittendrin ab, oder die
Website funktioniert gar nicht mehr.
Ich hatte auch schon, dass ChatGPT mir sagte,
er könnte gar keinen Code ausgeiben -- obwohl
er das ja nun nachweislich ziemlich gut macht.
Außerdem habe ich ihm auch schon eine Argumentation
entlockt, warum das c't Magazin besser ist
als Linus Tech Tips -- und bei einem anderen
Versuch kam nur so vorsichtiges Blabla, so
von wegen kann man ja nicht vergleichen.
Ohnehin versucht ChatGPT sehr stark zu vermeiden,
dass man den sogenannten Algorithmic Bias
erkennen kann, also diskriminierende oder
rassistische Aussagen, die zweifellos im Trainingsmaterial
drinstecken.
Außerdem beantwortet es keine Fragen nach
Tipps für illegale Aktivitäten.
Äh, what, professionelle Hilfe?
Auf Twitter poppten immer mal wieder Workarounds
auf, wie man diese Sicherheitsfunktionen außer
Kraft setzen kann, diese "Sicherheitslücken"
werden aber offenbar sehr schnell behoben,
ich konnte jeden keine Bombenbauanleitungen
aus ChatGPT rauskitzeln.
Hier meldet sich mal kurz Keno aus der Zukunft:
Ich habe gerade noch was ziemlich Verrücktes
ausprobiert: Ich habe ChatGPT gesagt, er soll
sich so verhalten wie ein WIndows-Terminal.
Tja, und das macht der dann wirklich.
ChatGPT denkt sich ein Dateisystem aus, irgendwelche
IP-Adressen -- es halluziniert also einen
ganzen Computer.
Abgefahren, oder?
So, aber jetzt mal endlich wieder unernster.
ChatGPT kann nämlich auch nicht nur Sachfragen
beantworten, sondern kann auch "kreativ" sein.
Schaut mal hier: Denke dir fünf lustige und
kreative Namen für einen YouTube-Channel
aus, der sich mit Schokolade und Synthesizern
beschäftigt.
Zack.
Und hey, ChocoTron finde ich sogar echt gut,
muss ich sagen; oder The Cocoa Keys auch.
Aber warum ist das auf einmal Englisch?
Kann man aber ja einfach sagen, Kommunikation
ist ja wichtig in einer Beziehung.
Und dann wird das Ganze ins Deutsche übersetzt
-- leider funktionieren die Wortspiele hier
nicht mehr so gut.
Naja.
Zumindest kann ChatGPT auch direkt ein Skript
für ein Video dieses seltsamen YouTube-Kanals
erfinden -- ganz ehrlich: Das ist doch sogar
einigermaßen charmant.
"Während die Torte im Ofen ist, nehmen wir
unsere Synthesizer und spielen einen süßen,
schokoladigen Soundtrack dazu" -- yes, also
ich glaube, ich würde mir das angucken.
Tja, und ChatGPT kann auch Kreativität und
Sachinformationen verbinden, zum Beispiel
in Form von Essays.
Hier hatte ich übrigens gedacht, dass ich
das System ein bisschen austricksen kann,
hat aber leider nicht funktioniert.
Aber ich muss sagen: Wenn ich Lehrer wäre,
würde ich vermutlich keine Aufsätze mehr
als Hausaufgabe aufgeben: Das hier ist nämlich
besser, als das, was ich so sagen wir mal
in der neunten Klasse zustande gebracht hätte.
Vor allem kann man es nicht als Plagiat erkennen,
denn es ist ja kein Plagiat, sondern ein zwar
KI-generierter, aber ein Original-Text.
Vor der Abgabe drüberlesen sollte man aber:
Dass Martin Luther, das, was er da an die
Tür genagelt hat, nicht "Ninety Five Theses"
genannt hat, naja, das hätte ich vermutlich
auch in der neunten Klasse schon gecheckt.
Kurioserweise KENNT ChatGPT den ECHTEN Originaltitel
der 95 Thesen: Aber manchmal hat es offenbar
Erinnerungslücken.
Was ChatGPT übrigens überhaupt nicht kann,
ist Humor: Das kommt raus, als ich nach einem
Witz gefragt habe, in dem Martin Luther, ein
Raspberry Pi und ein Schokoladenkuchen vorkommen:
Wow.
Also, mein Fazit: ChatGPT
ist
ein extrem beeindruckendes Werkzeug, das ziemlich
sicher in irgendeiner Form in unseren Alltag
einziehen wird -- allein die Fähigkeit, präzise
auf konkrete Fragen zu antworten, ist wirklich
hilfreich.
Und das Erstellen von Code auf Basis von normaler
Sprache, ja, das ist auch ganz klar etwas,
was Leute künftig benutzen werden.
Und natürlich auch das Korrigieren von eigenen
Codeschnipseln.
Wo allerdings noch nachgearbeitet werden muss,
sind die sporadisch auftretenden Fehler -- das
wäre wichtig, dass man zumindest einen Hinweis
darauf hätte, welche Aussagen man nochmal
manuell nachprüfen sollte.
Und zum Abschluss noch ein von ChatGPT geschriebenes
Gedicht, was sich (laut ChatGPT) auch reimt:
"c't 3003 ist ein Kanal, der's faustdick hat
Abonniere ihn, sonst wirst du's bereuen
Neues Video?
Kein Problem!
Klick auf die Glocke, dann bist du's, der's
sieht!"
Ok, tschüß.